le monde du sport et vie noailles
bousculé par le couvre-feu annoncé ce
mercredi soir par emmanuel macron
certains matchs de basketball ou de
handball programmé en soirée sont d'ores
et déjà annulés dans le département au
club de football de poissy ne devrait
pas y avoir de conséquences sur les
matches à domicile de l'équipe senior
des rencontres de nationale 2 son
programme est généralement en fin de
journée mais ce sont les rencontres à
l'extérieur en bretagne qui interroge
les dirigeants le match se déroule à 18
heures donc à 20h45 ce qu'il faut une
heure de battement nous partons avec nos
équipes devront nous restait
effectivement sur la bretagne les frais
nécessaires et supplémentaires dont ce
sera difficile à supporter compte tenu
notre budget rester sur place de la
personne sur un hôtel effectivement ce
n'est pas envisageable pour nous
néanmoins si nous rentrons j'espère
vraiment nous aurons des dérogations au
delà des matches ce couvre feu va
entraîner une réorganisation des
horaires d'entraînement le soir pour
l'ensemble des clubs yvelinois c'est le
cas au rugby-club de versailles
les conséquences sont surtout
organisationnel avec l'avancée de tous
les deux tout les horaires
d'entraînement notamment pour les
seniors et les juniors qui s'entraînait
jusqu'à 21h30 20h30
évidemment avant c'est désormais à 19
heures pour terminer à 20h15 20h30 grand
maximum et pour que tout le monde soit
rentré chez soi à 21h la vie autour des
rencontres va également être perturbé
les après matchs si renommé dans le
monde du rugby vont être impactés par
les nouvelles mesures annoncées
3e mi-temps sont remplacés par des
distributions sans rassemblement de
manière à éviter que le virus ne se
propage
après les matches et dans des conditions
dans des acquisitions festive qui sont
du coup à revoir mais encore une fois
tant qu'on peut jouer au rugby on fait
avec
il faudra faire avec pendant au minimum
quatre semaines pour le sport et vie
noir